get the image of the lifestyle you want
at whatever point in the future and you
make it super tangible like you can feel
it you can smell it you can see it but
not getting specific at all about what
your work is like are you in the
countryside are you in a city is it
you're at the Bohemian bar in the Lower
East Side and around all these artists
are you in a field and you've been out
in the sun and like working on your
Trails like what are you up in the
mountains like get that really clear and
then say great let me work backwards now
to figure out how do I get there with my
work and I think that's such a critical
way of thinking about things because hey
it's not just hey Follow Your Passion or
something like this because the right
answer might be I'm going to go to
medical school so that I can get these
Nightingale shifts where I work three
times a week one week out of the month
or something like that it's the highest
hourly rate I can get and then I can
spend the whole summer in the Canary
Islands it can lead you to really
interesting places I think it's the way
to do it